joining us now is Charles Road director
of mortgages at UK Finance hi hi good
morning thanks for joining us on the
program this morning your boss the CEO
said last week
um as far as the budget was concerned um
strong backing of the financial services
sector as being the Catalyst for the UK
economy so full of praise for the
chancellor
um do you think he still feels that way
this morning I think in terms of the um
the comments that he made at the time
yes he does what's happened is of course
the markets have interpretedness in a
different way and this is where we're
seeing the turmoil coming through in the
in the mortgage markets at the moment
but what I would what I would say is
that there are plenty of mortgage
products out there in the market for
consumers looking to purchase a property
or to move on to take a remortgage why
do you think the markets are wrong and
that your boss is right I'm not saying
the markets are wrong what I'm saying is
in terms of
um the comments that my boss made at the
time David posting he made at the time
was the reflect reflection of
um the the budget that the uh the
chancellor announced and the the steps
that he was taking to uh to help
consumers in terms of the cost of living
challenge they were facing and also to
make sure that the UK financial markets
are an attractive place for firms to do
business it hasn't worked there has it
right at this stage um you know that the
markets are interpreting it differently
um we we are seeing a little bit more
stability coming through into the market
so um over the last couple of days are
we in what way well in terms of the uh
at the Pounders firmed up against the
dollar a little bit over the last couple
of days no it hasn't I think it's um was
it 106 107 overnight it was 107
overnight but it's picked up from the
103 that it was three was on the Asian
markets and it wasn't actually here in
the UK so it's not really picked up at
all has it and the international
monetary fund the lender of Last Resort
as we know has stepped in to say
um that it's he's on the wrong course
and he needs to change direction yeah I
can't comment on the now on the the
Chancellor's comment and the chancellors
um uh decisions at this stage and I know
that the IMF have commented overnight
and that's for something for the
government to to pick up rather than UK
yeah but the impact on your business has
been astronomical hasn't it in what way
in that people can't get mortgages I
mean of course there are mortgage
mortgage products available but we're
seeing some of their big names like
Skipton and Halifax and virgin money are
saying we're not sure where this is
going so we're going to pull out for now
or offer different style mortgages that
they didn't previously there are still 3
000 mortgage products available
um on the market there's plenty of
choice for consumers and whether they're
looking to purchase a home or to
remortgage at this stage
um so there's certainly no shortage of
mortgages there are still there is more
mortgage on offer at this stage than
there was at uh in the start of 2020 the
pandemic when a similar issue occurred
in relation to reduction in mortgages
what are the interest rates looking like
how much is it going to cost people
in terms of taking out a new mortgage at
the moment it depends on in terms of
their loan to value and in terms of the
the borrower one of the things that we
would say and we would encourage all
consumers is to uh to speak to your
mortgage advisor and independent
mortgage advisor early if you're looking
to remortgage they will be able to find
the best product for you if you're
finding that you're in financial
difficulties then we would encourage um
borrowers whether it's secured or
unsecured mortgage borrowing to speak to
your lender at an early stage they stand
ready to help they've got a good
experience in this and they they want to
ensure the consumers get the right
product for their circumstances Bank of
England suggesting that interest rates
could go up to six percent what will
that mean for mortgages I can't comment
on what future speculation is in terms
of mortgages what I would say is that
everybody who's taken out a mortgage
since 2012 has been stress tested
they've had a stress test above three
percent above the lender's standard
variable rate to ensure that where there
is Market turbulence or movement in
markets that um that there is an
elements of of affordability built in
there and that's a learning from what
happened before the financial crisis in
2007-2008. if mortgages do if interest
rates do go up next year to you know
five six seven percent I'm asking you to
comment specifically on the number what
will that mean for people who have
um fluctuating more as opposed to fixed
rate what will that mean for people who
you know have a mortgage that fluctuates
with the market so in terms of someone
that's on a variable rate mortgage or a
track a mortgage one of the things that
we would say is again always speak to
your mortgage advisor to see where
there's a better product that's
available for you but in terms of the
um banks are there ready to help
borrowers who are facing financial
difficulty and will help customers
switch to a fixed rate product if that
is right for them at that particular
time and their their circumstances how
long have you been in the business in UK
Finance right and UK Finance I've been
here for two and a half years I've
watched in the mortgage market for over
20 years and how would you compare
what's happening now with the rest of
your career in terms of what I've seen
before I've seen I've seen it worse um
so in terms of the in terms of the late
1990s and also in terms of the after the
financial crisis when we to array a
significant reduction in house prices
and also in terms of an increase in
unemployment at that particular time as
well I'm also just going back to your
CEO he said further tax changes and
ambitious regulatory reform are required
to capitalize on this bold first move so
he wanted to see taxes cut further one
wonders what impact that would have
yeah I mean I can't comment on those
yeah but you represent the business so
obviously yes yes I I represent the
business but in terms of in terms of the
tax tax cuts that he would like to see
there would be tax cuts and changes to
encourage
firms to invest in the UK and to
encourage investment at all levels of
the economy to help the government in
terms of their agenda in relation to
leveling up and also in terms of making
sure that we have a vibrant and buoyancy
economy which encourages investment both
from overseas firms and also from UK
firms so as far as UK Finance is
concerned the chancellor is on the right
track
when UK Finance sits at the moment we
are supportive of what the government is
trying to do
um and we will are also supportive in
terms of our members in terms of the
mortgage there are mortgage firms as I
said at the beginning there is plenty of
mortgage on offerings in the Market at
the moment and we want to ensure that
borrowers have Choice which they do have
if they're looking to remove some more
money yeah and that's a reflection of
marketing economics rather than a
reflection on what the mini budget's
done
um in terms of where we are in terms of
this current phase in the cycle things
will start to level out we are seeing
that firms have those firms that have
withdrawn their products are putting
them back on the market this morning
okay okay so as far as Virgin Media is
concerned as far as Halifax is concerned
I think the other one was skipped and if
I'm not wrong they're all going to be
back on the market this morning that not
not necessarily those three phones a
number of firms are coming coming back
with new products this morning and
towards the end of this week as well